real 92.3 sauce walk is here come on
Ace time stay down splashing the high
Fest and the reason why they always
asking flying on the carpet like a
legend this Deuce will happen quietly
okay one of the most influential rappers
in the last 10 years or so I'd say
quietly thank you I appreciate that you
know yeah absolutely you know if I don't
say something myself it should have been
a little louder they need to respect it
but I feel like you've influenced a lot
of artists that you don't get credit for
hey this man knows something you're kind
of like the Houston Draco like I feel
like Draco get don't get the creditors
right God Rest a solo
he definitely put a Cadence out there
that is heavily used and heavily
re-implemented and you know recycled the
the open up a door doors for a lot of La
based artists and West Coast artists
agenda for sure I'll give you I give
that to both shows Texas is on fire
right now we are I open that door yeah
you're killing it uh thank you big X the
plug yes that Mexican OT yes
[Music]
it sure does
are you smacking cheeks on the internet
Emma
Emma yeah the only fans came back giving
the feet so your dick's definitely on
the internet
Jesus
look for that girl watching they want to
use a credit card and swipe their
[__] or send me a DM so she can
beat him which bag is bigger the hip-hop
bag or the only Fan's bag at this point
where they rival each other it's a hard
battle it's like it's like when I bet it
is it's like it's like when Goku about
Frieza and then he won but then Frieza
came back in a new form and then he
whooped Goku ass and then Goku has to go
call Vegeta if Vegeta came a new form of
the he got his ass whooping in cell came
it's some [__] like that because you
know what I'm saying cause only fans
might hit for 350 000 one month then one
money might hit for 900. Wow and then
one man rapping right here for two
million rapping my MP3 me I got 50 order
signs to my record label all streaming
on YouTube for number one you know what
I'm saying you you have a ton of
catalogs huge catalog have you I have
more albums in this Cadillac than they
got little cubicles in here you I know
at least five or six rappers that you
have DN to try to sign you're outside
you're active hitting pulls up I need it
all like Pokemon cards yeah Marsh
yeah hey man if you're looking for some
opportunity and you're searching for
some Unity come to the tsf community you
know I'm saying we hey man you need your
CEO just dancing at your shows and
getting you some hoes before you flows
you [__] with me
this building is like this here but we
also teach a financial literacy we also
teach people you know saying where they
invest their money how to understand
what catalog is how to leverage your
catalog how to make money from
reinvesting your catalog understand what
publishing is how to make money from
publishing doing sync licensing it's
also a whole different type of
demographic and business savvy that goes
with this is not just chaos and
ignorance you know what I'm saying it's
business are you I mean
Griselda were you gonna do a Griselda
album because I know that's like fam
like yeah yeah you know you know it's
really a wild situation I'm saying but
it's it's really dope Honestly Hot me
and grazelda came together me and
gazelle came together because
um Westside had people around him there
was fans of me of my lyricism and I had
people around me there was fans in him
and his style and his lyricism the way
he dressed and my friends were like bro
you don't know about West Side gun in
them yeah these people from New York
like they hard like they rep you know
because Ghetto Gospel the Ghetto Gospel
album in the whole Jay-Z situation and
all that it had already came out and you
know like a little bit before gazelle to
really start having a big big wave I was
already like picking up in that whole
backpack hip hop lyric lyrical yeah
cause you are a [__] rappers rapper
absolutely I'm the rapper's favorite
rapper the rapper's favorite influencer
and the rappers rapper with lyricism
that's why I'm looking for the best
don't put me on the song with Kendrick
and J Cole and and then Nas and and
bring Tupac Back and rest in peace so
the great one whoever y'all want to go
get just bring them to the Samurai and
we're gonna go to the table and see
who's able
uh I just got into this show Yellowstone
have you heard of it yeah the one from
Houston no well it's about Cowboys in
Montana oh yeah okay it got me like
super intrigued throughout the rodeo and
then I saw a bun B
Houston Rodeo you've been to the Houston
Rodeo I've been going to the Houston
Rodeo my whole life it's so crazy you
say that cause my uncle been talking
about
perform at the rodeo for a couple years
I would just be a little too busy and
having stuff going on but you know me
and I'm going to be working on that
right now and the Houston Rodeo is like
it's like a religion almost to a certain
people it looks like it's a Vibe for
sure it's a super Vibe it's it's it's
it's it's kind of like it's it was it's
like the hot 90s summer jam thing with
protection but for Texas but it's like
people just there that don't care about
rap right we don't even care about
hip-hop but we love it because we can't
you can't have Texas without hip-hop you
can't have Texas without the culture
that we everybody attacks from you don't
remember Power Water Johnny thing every
nationality yeah no I'm saying that's
what I'm saying outside of the obvious
the Rapper Lost the screwed up because
the TSS every nationality in Houston in
Texas is engulfed in music I was gonna
ask you like what would you because I
feel like right now Texas hip-hop is in
the best place it's been since since
absolutely
and even Dallas is catching away nah
Dallas doing that thing Daddy's popping
again too like like what what is
attributed to that obviously yourself
because you've been putting in constant
and we got to give it up to Megan and
Travis yeah for sure but I just mean
like the up and coming like that like
when I hear that Mexican OT I'm he
sounds like Texas yeah for sure you
sound like yeah it sounds like it sounds
like Texas we're bringing the sound but
you know so you know to be honest with
you um
at the time that I came out really to be
real like that's what you would have to
believe it like with me and Travis like
you know I'm saying like we the two
people that brought completely different
sounds to Texas that still resembled and
emulated everything that is Texas and
did it at a time where it was the
hardest to blow up in Texas in like get
get an audience not only from the
streets but get an audience from the
world and and you know just the masses
um
and also battling you know the rules and
regulations of Texas culture and being
indifferent that's a big thing too
um I would probably say another person
like on a on the party side of that
would be like a b king you know what I'm
saying
you you got to say Godzilla Club
Godzilla yeah yeah like that you gotta
say his name too or as far like us we
all got everybody 10 years a lot of
people tapped in with his sauce a little
bit yeah yeah no for sure that's why I
give it to him I give it to him but what
I did for Texas though is like on
comparable of having like you can't
compare what I did foreign
body like the independent grind of what
we know to be and I'm sure you've had
plenty of opportunities to do the major
label route and to do this and that but
right and then it's another thing is too
is like majority of artists that come
from Texas because all the politics and
all of the constituencies and rules that
come from being born in Texas and going
through out of that they when they do
have the opportunity and they make their
moment they get out of Texas they get as
far away from Texas as they can I stayed
the entire time and not only that I
stayed I stayed and I played I created
opportunity I shared the doors I opened
I did songs with people I helped
platforms like say cheese become say
cheese I stood next to Sean cotton
throughout his whole journey to create
that play he also did that for me and my
record lab when it helped me throughout
my journey as well but me and him met in
the middle of South by Southwest is two
nobody kids with with a dream and
opportunity and money yeah he's killing
he got he's got his like he just he just
I saw you
all the stuff with cars and real estate
but we all started
like with our own podcast bone blogs our
own style because we didn't have the
access to the blast in the world stars
so when that is what made Texas have the
opportunities in the doors that it has
now because
a Texas artist we had no Lane right for
sure we had no identity for sure we had
nowhere to to display or show the
identity yeah Travis blew up and went
worldwide with the major labels but it
didn't he gave the people style he gave
people motivation he gave people away to
dress in a way to look and brought the
because like hairstyles and all this to
grills like there's a lot of big
important [__] that Travis did for for
the for the culture like that fashion
you can't business clothes like princess
you can't take none of that but people
didn't know how to do it right they
didn't know how they didn't get it it
was like he blew up overnight out of
nowhere they didn't they don't know his
story we all went to school together I
went to school Travis my twin we went to
we all like was on in the same I went to
a bunch of different schools in Houston
I'm like a Houston baby that was
everywhere so like we know his stories
like everybody know my story and that
also and then they plays a big part in
the whole Houston thing and then what
Megan did she just did it for the women
she just she took with me and Travis did
and brought it for the women and mixed
The Pimp C with it and screwed up
clicking just you know I'm saying credit
I didn't a lot of girls take them away
Houston is just a place a lot of people
take a lot of sauce and a lot of
inspiration and a lot of you know skills
there from but because
where we are placed in hip-hop where we
are placed in America where we're
placing the map in the industry we don't
necessarily have the same Publications
in in defense mechanisms to and our
culture does not support
for sure like how New York does in La a
person from California is not going to
allow nobody else it don't matter from
Detroit we might rep on the same type of
Visa I'm not going to allow you to take
a a
draco's of cadence or uh uh blue face
reverse of the Cadence or what's the
other dude oh they Greedo a person from
La is going to identify that is our
style of music you think about ASAP
Rocky you think about dragging about all
these huge artists who I just ride with
them just tons of fingerprints in Texas
hey Chris that's porzingis just walked
in I'm kidding
um
sorry there's this tall white guy it
looks like Chris has four ziggas I'm
like hey congrats going to the Celtics
um I was going to ask you uh two more
questions one which
State Cali Texas who's got the best
Mexican food
be honest
I love Kevin
I love everything about California but
y'all ain't like y'all close to them
y'all close to the Mexicans to get their
Mexican food but y'all ain't like we got
the other type of Mexicans like we got
the real Mexicans that don't even speak
or think English act English or nothing
like we real Tech still you got Tex-Mex
that you got real Mexican food that's
coming from around the corner the border
is like four minutes from certain parts
of us two minutes one second all right
we could be a Mexican Mexico
I know you because I'm from L.A I was
the first time I went to I was in uh
Dallas I'm asking is a different type of
Mexican bro but it's up right now Hotel
food
what's better anything I had in L.A
food this has got the best barbecue
Texas got the best food period in a lot
of shapes and forms of fashion come on
please
[Music]
we're getting wrapped up you gotta come
on the podcast like a two-hour class I
know oh yeah I know you know what it is
my guy I appreciate you brother yes sir